Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能在轨道上通过。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Whether in the game or in life, the right coverage can make all the difference. Securian Canada gives you that coverage. For more than 65 years, Securian Canada has been helping Canadians build secure tomorrows. Their insurance solutions are designed to help protect you and your loved ones financially, giving you the peace of mind to focus on what truly matters.
保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。无论是在比赛中还是在生活中，合适的保障都能带来截然不同的结果。Securian Canada 为您提供这种保障。65 年多来，Securian Canada 一直在帮助加拿大人建立安全的未来。他们的保险解决方案旨在帮助您和您的家人在经济上获得保障，让您能够安心专注于真正重要的事情。
Find their products through banks, credit unions, and associations, or visit SecurianCanada.ca. Securian Canada, insurance designed for life. I have lived a long time, and I have seen a great deal, and I have always had a reason for everything I have done. Every act of my life has had an object in view, and no man can say that I have neglected facts or failed to think. I am one of the last chiefs of the independent Sioux Nation, and the place I hold among my people was held by my ancestors before me.
您可以通过银行、信用合作社和协会找到他们的产品，或访问 SecurianCanada.ca。Securian Canada，为生活而设计的保险。我活了很久，见识过很多事情，我所做的一切总是有理由的。我生命中的每一个行为都有一个目标，没有人能说我忽视了事实或没有思考。我是独立苏族（Sioux Nation）最后的酋长之一，我在族人中所处的地位，我的祖先在我之前也曾拥有。
If I had no place in the world, I would not be here, and the fact of my existence entitles me to exercise any influence I possess. I am satisfied that I was brought into this life for a purpose. Otherwise, why am I here? This land belongs to us, for the Great Spirit gave it to us when he put us here. We were free to come and go and to live in our own way. But white men who belong to another land have come upon us and are forcing us to live according to their ideas. That is an injustice. We have never dreamed of making white men live as we live. What would you do if your home was attacked you would stand up
如果我在这个世界上没有立足之地，我就不会在这里，我存在的这一事实使我有权行使我所拥有的任何影响力。我确信我来到这个世界上是有目的的。否则，我为什么会在这里？这片土地属于我们，因为伟大的神灵（Great Spirit）把我们安置在这里时，就把土地给了我们。我们曾经可以自由来去，以我们自己的方式生活。但属于另一片土地的白人来到我们这里，强迫我们按照他们的想法生活。那是不公正的。我们从未想过要让白人像我们一样生活。如果你的家园受到攻击，你会怎么做？你会站出来
like a brave man and defend it that is our story i have spoken so that uh dominic was uh sitting bull again yeah it's great to have him back on the show. Who introduced the last episode. And I think that my resonant Bull-like voice. Yeah. Very powerfully conveyed. You do think that, do you? Yes. That's nice that you think it. Don't you think?
像个勇敢的人一样保卫它，这就是我们的故事。我刚才说的是……呃，多米尼克，那是坐牛（Sitting Bull）又回来了。是的，很高兴他能回到节目中。是谁介绍了上一集？我想是我那洪亮如牛的声音。是的，传达得非常有力量。你真的这么认为吗？是的。你这么想真好。你不觉得吗？
I felt there was a little bit of Gordon Brown in there. He also is a kind of slightly ponderous but impressive person. Right, Yeah. Anyway, so that was Sitting Bull. And he was giving an interview to a Canadian journalist called James Creelman in 1882, which is six years after Little Bighorn. Yes. And is that when he is still in Canada? Because he goes to Canada after. Yes, he does go to Canada.
我觉得里面有一点戈登·布朗（Gordon Brown）的影子。他也是那种有点沉闷但令人印象深刻的人。对，是的。总之，那就是坐牛。那是他在 1882 年接受一位名叫詹姆斯·克里尔曼（James Creelman）的加拿大记者采访时说的，那是小大角战役（Little Bighorn）六年之后。是的，那是他还在加拿大时吗？因为他后来去了加拿大。是的，他确实去了加拿大。
He was being held in a place called Fort Randall at the time. And what hangs over that whole interview is, I mean, this is just Creelman's account of it, right? Of course, yeah. So is that actually what Sitting Bull said? Is Creelman embellishing it for his readers who expect Sitting Bull to say slightly ponderous, semi-spiritual things of that kind? Or did Sitting Bull say it?
当时他被关在一个叫兰德尔堡（Fort Randall）的地方。整个采访笼罩着一种氛围，我是说，这只是克里尔曼的叙述，对吧？当然，是的。那么，这真的是坐牛所说的吗？是克里尔曼为了迎合那些期待坐牛说出那种略显沉闷、半灵性话语的读者而进行的润色吗？还是坐牛真的说了这些话？
And is Sitting Bull consciously playing a part? As of course, I mean, he literally goes on to play a part, doesn't he? Yeah. Because he appears in Buffalo Bill's touring show. Well, Dominic, I mean,
而且坐牛是有意识地在扮演一个角色吗？当然，我的意思是，他后来确实去扮演了一个角色，不是吗？是的。因为他出现在了布法罗·比尔（Buffalo Bill）的巡回演出中。嗯，多米尼克，我的意思是，
we know he didn't actually say that because he didn't speak much English. Right. So apparently the phrases of English that he spoke were, hello, you bet, and see the boo. See the boo? A sitting bull.
我们知道他实际上并没有那样说，因为他不太会说英语。对。所以显然他会说的英语短语是：“你好”（hello）、“你打赌”（you bet）和“坐牛”（see the boo）。“坐牛”？即坐牛（Sitting Bull）。
Oh, right. Okay. And how much tea, which apparently was either how much or how are you? Or can I borrow a match? Hold on. They're very different things. Can I borrow a match and how are you?
哦，对。好的。还有“多少茶”（how much tea），显然这要么是“多少”（how much），要么是“你好吗”（how are you）？或者“能借个火吗”（can I borrow a match）？等等。它们是非常不同的东西。能借个火吗和你好吗。
Well, there was disagreement among people who knew him. No phrase adequately expresses both of those thoughts, I think. And also he was very keen on shaking hands. Was he? That's nice. So we've never done a history of the handshake. Of course, Donald Trump and Emmanuel Macron
嗯，认识他的人之间存在分歧。我想没有哪个短语能充分表达这两种想法。而且他还非常热衷于握手。是吗？那很好。所以我们从来没有做过关于握手历史的节目。当然，唐纳德·特朗普和埃马纽埃尔·马克龙
had that incredibly long handshake, didn't they, where neither of them would let go. So Sitting Bull might have enjoyed that. I think he probably would. I mean, I'm not sure whether he went around kind of crunching the hands of people.
进行了那次令人难以置信的长握手，不是吗？他们谁都不肯松手。所以坐牛可能也会喜欢那样。我想他可能会。我是说，我不确定他是否会到处去捏别人的手。
Right. I mean, he might have done because the thing about Sitting Bull, he's simultaneously kind of very charming. People really like him. He's great fun, isn't he? He's good-humoured. But, I mean, he's also simultaneously terrifying. kind of very charming. People really like him. He's great fun, isn't he? He's good-humoured.
对。我是说，他可能会这样做，因为关于坐牛的一点是，他同时又非常有魅力。人们真的很喜欢他。他很有趣，不是吗？他很有幽默感。但是，我是说，他同时也令人恐惧。非常有魅力。人们真的很喜欢他。他很有趣，不是吗？他很有幽默感。
But, I mean, he's also simultaneously terrifying. Yes, he is. I agree. I mean, he fights and fights, and he does the whole killing and mutilating stuff as well. Yeah. Personally, Tom, I find him more congenial than Crazy Horse. But you don't really know about Crazy Horse.
但是，我是说，他同时也令人恐惧。是的，他是。我同意。我是说，他不断地战斗，他也做了所有那些杀戮和肢解的事情。是的。就我个人而言，汤姆，我觉得他比疯马（Crazy Horse）更讨人喜欢。但你对疯马了解不多。
Well, I never like a loner. I don't like an eccentric. And Crazy Horse, you know, he didn't turn up to meetings, went a loner. I don't like an eccentric. And Crazy Horse, you know, he didn't turn up to meetings, went off on his own, didn't wear enough clothes. He saw himself as a little bit different, where a sitting bull is more conventional, I would say. He conforms to stereotype more than Crazy Horse does. And I like that in a man. I don't think he's conforming to stereotype. I think he's upholding the customs of his people. Yeah. Well, that's what I like. I like a traditionalist.
嗯，我从来不喜欢独来独往的人。我不喜欢怪人。而疯马，你知道，他不参加会议，是个独行侠。我不喜欢怪人。而疯马，你知道，他不参加会议，独自离开，穿的衣服也不够。他认为自己有点与众不同，而坐牛更传统，我会这么说。他比疯马更符合刻板印象。我喜欢男人身上有这种特质。我不认为他在迎合刻板印象。我认为他是在维护他族人的习俗。是的。嗯，这就是我喜欢的。我喜欢传统主义者。
Fair enough. So we should perhaps get back to the story. So, I mean, just to remind listeners, we've got this extra episode because Dominic, I mean, this has never happened before. Oh, never. You've gone the full Dan Carlin and what was meant to be four episodes is spiraling out of control. There's a spectrum, isn't there? You've got Dan Carlin at one end and actually another Dan at the other, Dan Snow. And we're somewhere, we've moved from the snow.
有道理。所以我们也许应该回到故事上来。所以，我是说，提醒一下听众，我们有这一集额外的节目，因为多米尼克，我是说，这以前从未发生过。哦，从来没有。你完全变成了丹·卡林（Dan Carlin），原本计划的四集节目现在失控了。有一个光谱，不是吗？一端是丹·卡林，另一端是另一位丹，丹·斯诺（Dan Snow）。我们处于某个位置，我们已经从斯诺那里走出来了。
Well, we're definitely moving from Dan Snow to Dan Carlin. We are. Listen, that's too much inside baseball. We should talk about history. So last time we talked, didn't we, about Native Americans generally, about how this is a world of shifting alliances, of people constantly moving around, of war. And it's also a changing one.
嗯，我们肯定是从丹·斯诺转向了丹·卡林。我们是。听着，那太内行了。我们应该谈谈历史。所以上次我们谈到了，不是吗，关于美洲原住民，关于这是一个联盟不断变化、人们不断迁移、充满战争的世界。而且它也是一个不断变化的世界。
So it's not a timeless traditional world, but it's a culture transformed by the horse and by guns and so on and so forth. We talked about the Plains Indians, in particular the Dakota, who'd moved from Minnesota, sort of southwest towards Montana, Wyoming, and so on, and moved from woodland people to kind of plains people, and how they are feeling under tremendous pressure from mass migration, from the migration of American settlers westwards towards Oregon, California, and so on in the trails. And so that is what Sitting Bull is talking about.
所以它不是一个永恒的传统世界，而是一种被马匹、枪支等所改变的文化。我们谈到了平原印第安人，特别是达科他人（Dakota），他们从明尼苏达州向西南方向迁移到蒙大拿州、怀俄明州等地，从林地民族变成了平原民族，以及他们如何感受到来自大规模移民、来自美国定居者向西迁移到俄勒冈、加利福尼亚等地的巨大压力。所以这就是坐牛所谈论的内容。
Exactly, exactly. And railroads, which mean the death of the bison culture on which they have come to rely. And so last time we said, this comes to a bit of a peak in the mid-1860s the lakota think they've done brilliantly because they've finally seen off the crows and taken the powder river country which they're very keen on scalped them with their long big bear grease pomaded hair exactly the crows yes there's another theme in this isn't about hair products as well as um handshaking yeah which i wasn't anticipating when i when we began it, I have to say. No. So the crows have let themselves
正是，正是。还有铁路，这意味着他们所依赖的野牛文化的终结。所以上次我们说，这在 19 世纪 60 年代中期达到了一定的顶峰，拉科他人（Lakota）认为他们做得非常出色，因为他们终于赶走了克罗人（Crows），占领了他们非常渴望的粉河（Powder River）地区，用他们那长长的、涂满熊油的头发把他们头皮剥了下来。没错，克罗人，是的。这里还有另一个主题，关于护发产品以及握手，是的，我开始的时候并没有预料到这一点，我必须说。不。所以克罗人让自己
down with their pomades. I don't think so. I approve. I think they spent too much time on that, Tom, and not enough on military tactics. And that's what's cost them.
失望了，因为他们的发油。我不这么认为。我赞同。我认为他们花太多时间在那上面了，汤姆，而在军事战术上花的时间不够。这就是让他们付出代价的原因。
No, because they got wiped out by disease. Well, that's true too. And that's the difference with the Lakota, isn't it? Which, of course, they didn't because the Lakota are more nomadic
不，因为他们被疾病消灭了。嗯，那也是事实。这就是与拉科他人的区别，不是吗？当然，他们没有，因为拉科他人更游牧，
and they've been inoculated by missionaries. So, Red Cloud have got all this. He's the big't because the Lakota are more nomadic and they've been inoculated by missionaries. So Red Cloud had got all this. He's the big man in the Lakota world, although they're not a top-down kind of polity. And so he was outraged by the Bozeman Trail, Tom, which is your favorite trail. You're on record as saying that, aren't you? Yeah, it's a top trail. So Red Cloud is the political leader and actually Crazy Horse is the great military tactician.
而且他们已经接种了传教士带来的疫苗。所以，红云（Red Cloud）拥有了这一切。他是大人物，因为拉科他人更游牧，而且他们已经接种了传教士带来的疫苗。所以红云拥有了这一切。他是拉科他世界的大人物，尽管他们不是那种自上而下的政体。所以他对博兹曼小径（Bozeman Trail）感到愤怒，汤姆，那是你最喜欢的小径。你有记录说那是你最喜欢的，不是吗？是的，那是一条顶级小径。所以红云是政治领袖，而疯马实际上是伟大的军事战术家。
And it's Crazy Horse, who we talked about last time, who inspires the most celebrated, or indeed notorious, of all of the Lakota attacks on the American army, which is the so-called Fetterman Massacre or the Fetterman Fight. Well, I mean, it depends which side you're on, right? On your perspective, of course. Because if you're Lakota, you'd say it's a great victory. Of course you would. And if you're the Americans, you say it's a massacre.
正是疯马，我们上次谈到过他，他激发了拉科他人对美国军队最著名、甚至可以说是臭名昭著的攻击，即所谓的费特曼大屠杀（Fetterman Massacre）或费特曼之战（Fetterman Fight）。嗯，我是说，这取决于你站在哪一边，对吧？当然取决于你的视角。因为如果你是拉科他人，你会说这是一场伟大的胜利。你当然会这么说。如果你是美国人，你会说这是一场大屠杀。
Exactly. So Crazy Horse does this thing, which they often try to do the Lakota, and they normally make a mess of it. But in this case, it really works. They basically entice a group of American soldiers led by this chap, Captain William Fetterman. There's about 80 of them out of Fort Kearney. They decoy them out and then they ambush them.
正是。所以疯马做了这件事，这是拉科他人经常尝试做的事情，但他们通常会搞砸。但在这种情况下，它真的很有效。他们基本上引诱了一群由威廉·费特曼（William Fetterman）上尉领导的美国士兵。大约有 80 人从卡尼堡（Fort Kearney）出来。他们把他们引诱出来，然后伏击了他们。
And there are 81 of the Americans and every single one of them is killed. They are horrendously kind of mutilated afterwards. Or so it seems to the people who find the bodies, of course, as we talked about last time. Yeah. The Lakota argument is this means they won't be able to get us in the afterlife. Well, they will. I mean, they'll be in the afterlife, but they'll be kind of shuffling around without any eyes
美国人有 81 人，他们全部被杀。他们事后被极其残忍地肢解了。或者对于发现尸体的人来说似乎是这样，当然，正如我们上次谈到的那样。是的。拉科他人的论点是，这意味着他们无法在来世抓住我们。嗯，他们会。我是说，他们会在来世，但他们会像行尸走肉一样四处游荡，没有眼睛，
and with their testicles on rocks and their arms falling off and things. Precisely. So it's kind of the living dead. They'll be much less effective. But Dominic, you know, of course, what this reminds me as someone who's read British imperial history, I mean, this is a kind of very familiar episode from, you know, the Annals of Kipling or something, isn't it? Yeah. Kind of shades of the Northwest Frontier or Isanduana or... Oh, totally it is. Totally it is. People being lured out of forts.
睾丸在石头上，手臂掉下来等等。正是。所以这有点像活死人。他们的战斗力会大大降低。但是多米尼克，你知道，当然，作为一个读过大英帝国历史的人，这让我想起了什么，我是说，这是一个非常熟悉的插曲，来自吉卜林（Kipling）的年鉴之类的，不是吗？是的。有点西北边境或伊散德尔瓦纳（Isandlwana）的影子，或者……哦，完全是。完全是。人们被引诱出堡垒。
And the notion that this is not a kind of imperial project is clearly not true. I mean, it's very imperial. It's very, very like British military expeditions in the 19th century. Of course it is. Yes. It's like something that you would see in Afghanistan or the Northwest frontier or something. Yeah. And all of the baggage that goes along with it.
而且认为这不是一种帝国主义项目的想法显然是不正确的。我是说，它非常帝国主义。它非常、非常像 19 世纪的英国军事远征。当然是。是的。这就像你在阿富汗或西北边境看到的东西。是的。以及随之而来的所有包袱。
So on the one hand, the idea of the kind of the noble savage. And on the other hand, the idea of kind of our plucky boys who are only trying to export civilization and that kind of liberal norms yeah but have found themselves in a world they don't understand i mean all of that is exactly the same heart of darkness heart of darkness exactly so the fetterman massacre is a shocking event you know it's just over a year after the civil war east coast opinion is horrified by it. But the interesting thing is that unlike Little Bighorn, it doesn't provoke massive American reprisals.
所以一方面，是那种“高贵的野蛮人”的想法。另一方面，是那种“我们勇敢的男孩，他们只是试图输出文明和那种自由规范”的想法，是的，但发现自己处于一个他们不理解的世界。我是说，所有这些都和《黑暗之心》（Heart of Darkness）一模一样。《黑暗之心》，正是。所以费特曼大屠杀是一件令人震惊的事件，你知道，它发生在内战结束后一年多一点，东海岸的舆论对此感到震惊。但有趣的是，与小大角战役不同，它并没有引发美国大规模的报复。
It has two or three interesting repercussions. Number one, everybody knows that Crazy Horse is responsible. And it's this fight, this ambush that enshrines him in the American imagination as the supreme warlord. Right. So one of the reasons, surely, why it doesn't impact on American public consciousness in the way that Bighorn does is that the defeated person is not as glamorous and exciting and charismatic as Custer. Yeah, Captain Fetterman. Yeah. But it's interesting that the Lakota commander, Crazy Horse, does have that element of charisma. Yes.
它有两三个有趣的连锁反应。第一，每个人都知道疯马是负责人。正是这场战斗、这次伏击，使他在美国人的想象中被尊为至高无上的军阀。对。所以，它没有像小大角战役那样影响美国公众意识的原因之一，肯定是因为被击败的人不像卡斯特（Custer）那样迷人、令人兴奋和富有魅力。是的，费特曼上尉。是的。但有趣的是，拉科他人的指挥官疯马确实拥有那种魅力。是的。
And so he does imprint himself on the popular imagination. Yeah, he does. So there does seem to be a kind of quite a strong element that these engagements, you know, their profile depends on the stature of the commanders. I think that's fair. And I think it depends when they happen as well. This is happening in the middle of the US is in the throes of reconstruction so all the attention is on the old confederacy and what's happening there but in 1876 at little bighorn it's the nation's birthday and they want a nice birthday present that a feat of the lakota and when it turns out the other way around it becomes
所以他确实在公众想象中留下了深刻的印象。是的，他确实。所以似乎确实有一个相当强的因素，这些交战，你知道，它们的知名度取决于指挥官的地位。我认为这很公平。而且我认为这也取决于它们发生的时间。这发生在内战重建时期，所以所有的注意力都集中在旧邦联和那里发生的事情上，但在 1876 年的小大角战役中，那是国家的生日，他们想要一份好的生日礼物，那就是击败拉科他人，当结果恰恰相反时，它就变成了一个
such a resonant story and as you say it's custer who's already a celebrity secondly i think a really important thing up to this point, although the Lakota Sioux did have a kind of mystique with their headdresses and all that stuff, they weren't seen, I think, as uniquely terrifying, dangerous. Or formidable. Or formidable. And so I think it elevates them, as one historian says,
如此引起共鸣的故事，正如你所说，卡斯特本身就是一位名人。其次，我认为到目前为止一个非常重要的事情是，尽管拉科他苏族人凭借他们的头饰和所有那些东西有一种神秘感，但我认为他们并没有被视为极其可怕、危险的。或者令人生畏的。或者令人生畏的。所以我认为这提升了他们，正如一位历史学家所说，
into the most powerful and intransigent enemy on the plains. And people say this themselves internally. So General Sherman writes to Ulysses S. Grant a few weeks, I think, or a few days after the Fetima massacre. And he says, we must act with vindictive earnestness against the Sioux, even to their extermination, men, women and children. In other words, people are thirsting for revenge. Well, I mean, that's literally a genocidal mission statement. Yes, genocidal. And actually that language of extermination, we can perhaps talk about that a
成为平原上最强大、最不妥协的敌人。人们在内部也这样说。所以谢尔曼将军（General Sherman）在费特曼大屠杀后几周，我想，或者几天后，写信给尤利西斯·S·格兰特（Ulysses S. Grant）。他说，我们必须对苏族人采取报复性的严肃态度，甚至要将他们灭绝，包括男人、女人和孩子。换句话说，人们渴望复仇。嗯，我是说，那简直是一个种族灭绝的使命宣言。是的，种族灭绝。而且实际上那种灭绝的语言，我们也许可以稍后谈谈，
little bit later, how much they really mean that or how much they're just throwing around the word. Well, I mean, Sherman is a great one for vindictive earnestness, isn't he? Yes. But the really interesting thing is that actually the American reaction to this is to close the Bozeman Trail and to close the forts. To say, fine, you win. We'll go back home. Now, that might seem an extraordinary thing to do. The reason they do it, of course, is partly because the army, which has been cut the whole time, cannot do two things at once.
他们到底有多认真，或者他们只是在随意使用这个词。嗯，我是说，谢尔曼是一个非常擅长报复性严肃态度的人，不是吗？是的。但真正有趣的是，实际上美国对此的反应是关闭博兹曼小径并关闭堡垒。说，好吧，你们赢了。我们回家。现在，这看起来可能是一件非同寻常的事情。他们这样做的原因，当然，部分是因为军队，一直被削减，不能同时做两件事。
They cannot enforce order in the former Confederate South and south and the former slave south you know against paramountary violence and all these kinds of things and that is obviously the priority and that is the priority and it can't fight the lakota at the same time so they say sod the lakota just let's put a lid on this close the trail and all that and secondly i think the interesting thing is that american attitudes to the natives are always much more complicated and nuanced than we think so the trend now is to say well the whole Congress of the West was a genocidal project. Everybody hated the Indians. Irredeemably racist, all of this stuff.
他们不能在以前的南方邦联和南方，以前的奴隶制南方，你知道，对抗准军事暴力和所有这些事情，而这显然是优先事项，这是优先事项，它不能同时与拉科他人作战。所以他们说，去他的拉科他人，让我们控制住这个，关闭小径等等。其次，我认为有趣的是，美国人对原住民的态度总是比我们想象的要复杂和微妙得多。所以现在的趋势是说，嗯，整个西部的征服是一个种族灭绝的项目。每个人都讨厌印第安人。不可救药的种族主义，所有这些东西。
And of course, there is an element of truth in that. But for example, in the aftermath of the Fetterman fight, Congress has an investigation under Senator James Doolittle. And he says, well, the big problem here is not the Lakota. It's what he calls the aggressions of lawless whites, the steady and resistless. So Custer, I mean, Custer is very, very aware of the fact that there is a lot of public sympathy in the United States for the Lakota. And he kind of, East Coast liberals, it's kind of that talk. They don't know what they're talking about. They're at a distance. They haven't seen people with their eyeballs gouged out.
当然，其中有真实的一面。但例如，在费特曼之战后，国会在詹姆斯·杜利特尔（James Doolittle）参议员的领导下进行了调查。他说，嗯，这里的大问题不是拉科他人。而是他所说的“无法无天的白人的侵略”，那种稳定且不可抗拒的……所以卡斯特，我是说，卡斯特非常、非常清楚这样一个事实，即美国公众对拉科他人有很多同情。他有点……东海岸的自由派，就是那种谈话。他们不知道自己在说什么。他们离得很远。他们没有见过眼球被挖出来的人。
Yes. That kind of thing. You know, they don't know what they're talking about. They're at a distance. They haven't seen people with their eyeballs gouged out. That kind of thing. Yeah. I think that sort of tension, that political argument, there are always some people on the East Coast who say, this whole business is absolutely terrible. The poor Lakota, you know, I mean, even at this point, I think there are people who say the earth is weeping. Let us commune with the spirits and all that stuff. So this is why the paleontologist I mentioned yesterday,
是的。那种事情。你知道，他们不知道自己在说什么。他们离得很远。他们没有见过眼球被挖出来的人。那种事情。是的。我认为那种紧张关系，那种政治争论，东海岸总是有一些人说，整个事情绝对是可怕的。可怜的拉科他人，你知道，我是说，即使在这一点上，我认为也有人说大地在哭泣。让我们与灵魂交流等等。这就是为什么我昨天提到的古生物学家，
Charles Othniel Marsh, who is with COPE, they're the two rival paleontologists who are digging up dinosaurs, sending them back, attacking each other. Yeah. I mean, he's unbelievably sympathetic to the Lakota. He feels deep, deep shame as an American for what is happening. And I suppose because he is going out there as someone who's not a prospector, not a soldier, not someone who is trying to take things because
查尔斯·奥斯尼尔·马什（Charles Othniel Marsh），他和科普（COPE）在一起，他们是两个竞争的古生物学家，他们挖掘恐龙，把它们送回去，互相攻击。是的。我是说，他对拉科他人非常同情。他作为一个美国人，对正在发生的事情感到深深的、深深的羞耻。我想是因为他作为一个不是探矿者、不是士兵、不是试图夺取东西的人去那里，因为
Lakota don't mind if he digs up a Diplodocus or whatever. And he then, as I said, he becomes a big partisan of red clouds in Washington, a big friend. And Tom, the interesting thing is, isn't that your parallel with sort of the European empires yet again? Yeah. The heyday of the British empire, there are people who go out to India or whatever and are accused of going native,
拉科他人不介意他挖出梁龙（Diplodocus）什么的。然后，正如我所说，他成为了华盛顿红云的大党羽，一个好朋友。汤姆，有趣的是，这难道不是你再次与欧洲帝国进行的类比吗？是的。大英帝国的鼎盛时期，有些人去印度什么的，被指责“本土化”（going native），
of championing the locals over their own country and who become very conflicted about the imperial project. I mean, it's the same thing. Actually, President Andrew Johnson, who is always seen as one of the worst presidents in American history because of his role in Reconstruction, he's seen as this sort of terrible racist. He sets up a peace commission.
支持当地人反对自己的国家，并对帝国项目变得非常矛盾。我是说，这是一回事。实际上，安德鲁·约翰逊（Andrew Johnson）总统，他总是被视为美国历史上最糟糕的总统之一，因为他在重建中的角色，他被视为这种可怕的种族主义者。他成立了一个和平委员会。
And when that reports in 1868, it's actually really worth dwelling on this. The conclusion of the peace commission is, and I quote, if the lands of the white man are taken, civilization justifies him in resisting the invader. Civilization does more than this. It brands him a coward and a slave if he submits to the wrong. But if the savage resists, civilization with the 10 commandments in one hand and the sword in the other demands his immediate extermination. And the argument of the Peace Commission is not, well, therefore we should just let them get on with it and not expand. They do believe in manifest destiny as all of these people do, but they say, listen, we should be more straight with the Plains Indians.
当它在 1868 年报告时，实际上非常值得深思。和平委员会的结论是，我引用：“如果白人的土地被夺走，文明证明他抵抗入侵者是正当的。文明不仅如此。如果他屈服于错误，它会给他打上懦夫和奴隶的烙印。但如果野蛮人抵抗，文明一手拿着十诫，一手拿着剑，要求立即将他灭绝。”和平委员会的论点不是，好吧，因此我们应该让他们继续下去，不要扩张。他们确实相信“昭昭天命”（manifest destiny），就像所有这些人一样，但他们说，听着，我们应该对平原印第安人更坦率一些。
We should actually listen to them. We should be more sensitive. You know, all of this sort of stuff that actually now, from the perspective of 2024, you sort of think, well, there's a lot of truth in that, isn't there? I mean, they're never going to stop going. There's no conceivable alternative reality in which there aren't railroads across the West. Well, I mean, the other thing, of course, that is happening at this time, and Marsh is a representative figure of it because he's a great partisan of Darwin, is that notions of evolution and racial hierarchies and survival of the fittest is really starting to kick in at this point.
我们应该真正倾听他们的意见。我们应该更敏感。你知道，所有这些现在从 2024 年的角度来看，你有点认为，嗯，这其中有很多真理，不是吗？我是说，他们永远不会停止前进。没有一种可以想象的替代现实，西部没有铁路。嗯，我是说，当然，此时正在发生的另一件事，马什是其中的代表人物，因为他是达尔文的忠实拥护者，是进化论和种族等级制度以及适者生存的概念在此时真正开始发挥作用。
And I think it's possible for scientifically literate figures back in Washington to hold two contrary opinions in their head at the same time. Firstly, that pity for the Lakota and the Plains Indians more generally, kind of admiration for them, a feeling of regret, maybe even a feeling of shame at what is happening. But also they can kind of wash their hands of it and say, well, you know, this is what biology is all about. This is the way of the world. The strong replace the weak. And actually, Tom, I think that's dead right. Absolutely right. I think that kind of social Darwinism has permeated into mainstream culture, into mainstream political opinion. I mean, you could also almost argue that Darwinism takes off as fast as it does because
我认为华盛顿的科学素养人士在脑海中同时持有两种相反的观点是可能的。首先，对拉科他人和平原印第安人更普遍的怜悯，对他们的一种钦佩，一种遗憾的感觉，甚至是对正在发生的事情的一种羞耻感。但他们也可以洗手不干，说，嗯，你知道，这就是生物学。这就是世界的方式。强者取代弱者。而且实际上，汤姆，我认为那是完全正确的。绝对正确。我认为那种社会达尔文主义已经渗透到主流文化、主流政治舆论中。我是说，你几乎可以说达尔文主义之所以发展得如此之快，是因为
it's answering a need. Yeah, that's a good point. You know, people raised in Christian, in British or American contexts, in kind of democratic notions of fair play or whatever, they need a justification for what they're going to do anyway, which is basically to grab stuff, grab land, grab resources from people who are weaker than them. And actually, again and again, the characters in this story say things like that. So General Sherman, the guy who I quoted talking about the extermination of the Indians, he despises a lot of the white settlers and the miners and so on. And again and again, he will say they're behaving very badly. You know, if I were a Lakota.
它回答了一种需求。是的，那是一个很好的观点。你知道，在基督教、英国或美国背景下，在某种民主的公平竞争观念下长大的人，他们需要为他们无论如何都要做的事情辩护，这基本上就是从比他们弱的人那里抢东西、抢土地、抢资源。而且实际上，故事中的人物一次又一次地说出这样的话。所以谢尔曼将军，那个我引用谈论灭绝印第安人的人，他鄙视许多白人定居者和矿工等等。而且一次又一次，他会说他们的行为非常糟糕。你知道，如果我是拉科他人。
But then in the next breath, as Custer does, he will then say, however, it is the law of nature, it is the law of nature, it is the law of life, that civilization must proceed and steamroller this antiquated backward. I mean, they will say this again and again. So I think you're absolutely right that the Darwinist mentality is at the sort of center of American attitudes generally. Anyway, the upshot of it all is they sign a big treaty with the Lakota, with Red Cloud.
但随后在下一口气中，就像卡斯特所做的那样，他会说，然而，这是自然法则，这是自然法则，这是生命法则，文明必须前进，并用蒸汽压路机压过这种过时的落后。我是说，他们会一次又一次地说。所以我认为你绝对正确，达尔文主义心态处于美国普遍态度的中心。总之，这一切的结果是，他们与拉科他人、与红云签署了一项大条约。
Well, it's two-thirds of the Lakota, isn't it? About. Yes, we'll get to this. So they give them a huge reservation, the Great Sioux Reservation, and this will include pretty much all of modern-day South Dakota west of the Missouri. American listeners in particular will reflect
嗯，那是三分之二的拉科他人，不是吗？大约。是的，我们会谈到这一点。所以他们给了他们一个巨大的保留地，大苏族保留地（Great Sioux Reservation），这将包括密苏里河以西几乎所有现代的南达科他州。美国听众特别会反思
that not all of South Dakota currently belongs to the Lakota, so they will know how that ended up. And the promise is this will all be yours. We'll have agencies that will give you goods and stuff. But slightly confusingly, you can roam a little bit with your hunting. You can roam south. As long as there are abundant buffalo to justify the chase, you can roam. And the huge wilderness to the west of the
南达科他州目前并不完全属于拉科他人，所以他们会知道结果如何。承诺是这一切都将属于你们。我们将有代理机构提供商品和东西。但稍微令人困惑的是，你们可以带着狩猎稍微漫游一下。你们可以向南漫游。只要有充足的野牛来证明追逐的合理性，你们就可以漫游。保留地以西的巨大荒野，
reservation which is to say wyoming and montana that is designated very sort of confusingly as unseeded sioux territory so it's kind of yours but white people can settle there if they get your permission and the army can go in and do things. Again, they'll ask you first. So it's deliberately a very gray area. But actually, they sign the treaty. And at first, Red Cloud is very cross. He says, you're not obeying the treaty. And he actually makes a trip to Washington.
也就是怀俄明州和蒙大拿州，被非常令人困惑地指定为“未割让的苏族领土”（unseeded Sioux territory），所以它有点属于你们，但白人如果得到你们的许可就可以在那里定居，军队也可以进去做事情。同样，他们会先问你们。所以它故意是一个非常灰色的区域。但实际上，他们签署了条约。起初，红云非常生气。他说，你们没有遵守条约。他实际上去了华盛顿一趟。
He does, yeah. And everybody is very impressed with him. They say, what a tremendous fellow he is. So this is when all the photos are taken, isn't it, of him in top hats and things? Yes. And he actually goes to meet Ulysses S. Grant. And he says, you're not honouring the treaty. You're not keeping settlers out of the Black Hills and the Bighorn Mountains. And Grant actually says to him, fair enough. You're obviously an impressive bloke. We haven't
他去了，是的。每个人都对他印象深刻。他们说，他真是个了不起的家伙。所以这就是所有照片拍摄的时候，不是吗，他戴着高礼帽等等？是的。他实际上去见了尤利西斯·S·格兰特。他说，你们没有履行条约。你们没有让定居者远离黑山（Black Hills）和大角山（Bighorn Mountains）。格兰特实际上对他说，有道理。你显然是个令人印象深刻的家伙。我们没有
delivered. And so Red Cloud goes back and he says, well, brilliant. I've gone to see the great father in Washington and all is good. And actually, most of the Lakota follow his. He's a war hero, Red Cloud. So people say, you know what? He knows what he's talking about. And actually, we have to accommodate to reality. We'll go on the reservation. We'll get all the food and supplies.
兑现。所以红云回去了，他说，嗯，太棒了。我去见了华盛顿的伟大父亲，一切都很好。实际上，大多数拉科他人跟随他的。他是战争英雄，红云。所以人们说，你知道吗？他知道他在说什么。实际上，我们必须适应现实。我们将去保留地。我们将获得所有的食物和补给。
He manages to persuade most of the Lakota and a large number of Cheyenne and Arapaho, their usual kind of allies. Let's go on to this in South Dakota. You know, it's not ideal, but there's no point fighting reality. However, as you say, Tom, there are people who don't follow him. And they are particular groups. So the Hunkpapas, the Sansarks, the Blackfeet, the Two Kettles, the Mini-Condus, some of the Aglalas, and a Crazy Horse. Crazy Horse is like, no way am I going into a reservation.
他设法说服了大多数拉科他人和大量的夏延人（Cheyenne）和阿拉帕霍人（Arapaho），他们通常的盟友。让我们去南达科他州的这个地方。你知道，这并不理想，但战斗现实没有意义。然而，正如你所说，汤姆，有些人没有跟随他。他们是特定的群体。所以洪帕帕人（Hunkpapas）、桑萨克人（Sansarks）、黑脚人（Blackfeet）、双水壶人（Two Kettles）、米尼孔朱人（Mini-Condus）、一些奥格拉拉人（Aglalas）和疯马。疯马就像，我绝不会去保留地。
That's not my thing at all. Because, of course, he hates any sense of being confined, doesn't he, Crazy Horse? He's the man who walks alone. He does. He's wild as the wind. Yeah, wild as the wind, Tom. Very nice. And the guy who really says, no way, is the man you so beautifully voiced at the beginning of this episode and the last episode, and that is Sitting Bull. So I guess for us,
那根本不是我的风格。因为，当然，他讨厌任何被限制的感觉，不是吗，疯马？他是那个独自行走的人。他是。他像风一样狂野。是的，像风一样狂野，汤姆。非常好。而真正说“绝不”的家伙，就是你在本集开头和上一集开头配音的那个人，那就是坐牛。所以我猜对我们来说，
the idea of a sitting bull, it implies a kind of stationary quality, doesn't it? Yeah, it does. But a bull presumably is referring to the buffalo. Yes. And the buffalo is the most sacred animal on the plains. And it's a creature of a creature of immense power it is i mean you would not want to face a buffalo and he's a very impressive person i think he's a very impressive person sitting bull so as far as we know he's probably born in 1831 he's a hunk papa i love that name his sounds like a kind of 1970s children's yeah hunk papa hunk mama hunk kids barber papa actually do you know you're getting into the Sounds like a kind of 1970s children's. Yeah. Hunk Papa, Hunk Mama, Hunk Kids, Barber Papa.
坐牛的想法，它暗示了一种静止的品质，不是吗？是的，它确实。但“牛”（bull）大概是指野牛。是的。野牛是平原上最神圣的动物。它是一种拥有巨大力量的生物，我是说，你不会想面对一头野牛，而且他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，我认为他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，坐牛。所以据我们所知，他可能出生于 1831 年，他是洪帕帕人，我喜欢那个名字。听起来像某种 20 世纪 70 年代的儿童……是的，洪帕帕，洪妈妈，洪孩子，巴巴爸爸（Barber Papa），实际上你知道你正在进入……听起来像某种 20 世纪 70 年代的儿童。是的，洪帕帕，洪妈妈，洪孩子，巴巴爸爸。
Actually, do you know, you're getting into the world of the Teletubbers there, aren't you? No, I was thinking Barber Papa. Oh, okay. Yeah. Do you remember Barber Papa? It was kind of great and wobbly thing. Yeah. Or the Moomins.
实际上，你知道，你正在进入天线宝宝（Teletubbers）的世界，不是吗？不，我在想巴巴爸爸。哦，好的。是的。你记得巴巴爸爸吗？那是一种伟大而摇晃的东西。是的。或者姆明（Moomins）。
You could have been a Moomin. Anyway, listen, listen. This is very disrespectful to the Hunk Papas. It is. It is. It is. So his father is called Returns Again. Good name.
你本可以成为一个姆明。总之，听着，听着。这对洪帕帕人非常不尊重。是的。是的。是的。所以他的父亲叫“再次归来”（Returns Again）。好名字。
Odd name. But apparently this is because his father went out to fight some people once. And they all were going home. And his father said, I'm going back for more, actually. I love this. There's more of them left. And people called him Returns Again. You couldn't get him off the battlefield.
奇怪的名字。但显然这是因为他父亲曾经出去和一些人战斗。他们都回家了。他父亲说，我实际上要回去再打一场。我喜欢这个。他们还剩下更多的人。人们称他为“再次归来”。你无法让他离开战场。
And his mother is called Her Holy Door. And Returns Again is quite an impressive guy. He's a kind of head man of a lodge, which means he's got a group. He's not a chief, but he's got a group of several dozens, maybe even a hundred people, extended family. So he's the rising gentry.
他的母亲叫“神圣之门”（Her Holy Door）。“再次归来”是一个相当令人印象深刻的家伙。他是某种小屋的头人，这意味着他有一个群体。他不是酋长，但他有一个由几十人，甚至可能一百人组成的群体，大家庭。所以他是新兴的绅士。
Yeah, yeah. He's a prosperous yeoman farmer, Tom. Yes, that's what he is. He's the middling sort. He's kind of Sandbrook's person. Right, thanks. He's middle Sue. Yes, that's what he is. He's the middling sort. He's kind of Sandbrook's person. Right, thanks. He's middle Sue. Right, okay. So, he's
是的，是的。他是富裕的自耕农，汤姆。是的，他就是这样。他是中产阶级。他是桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）的人。对，谢谢。他是中苏族人。是的，他就是这样。他是中产阶级。他是桑德布鲁克的人。对，谢谢。他是中苏族人。对，好的。所以，他
a healer. Again, like you. Yeah, right. He's very brave. He has powerful dreams and visions, as I do. I think we've found the person in history who most resembles you. So you did a terrible thing the other day, because when I read out that description to Captain Benteen about how behind his chubby volubility was a...
是一个治疗师。和你一样。是的，对。他非常勇敢。他有强大的梦境和幻象，就像我一样。我想我们找到了历史上最像你的人。所以你前几天做了一件可怕的事情，因为当我读到对本廷（Benteen）上尉的那段描述时，关于他那胖乎乎的健谈背后是一种……
Sinister Machiavellian cruelty. So you said that. And then I was so shocked by that that later that day, I went to my wife and I read that passage out. I started reading that passage. What did she say? And I hadn't even got to the point where I said, Tom Holland said that reminded him of me. And before I i could say that she said you just read me something about yourself
阴险的马基雅维利式的残忍。所以你说了那个。然后我对此感到非常震惊，以至于那天晚些时候，我去找我妻子，读了那段话。我开始读那段话。她说了什么？我甚至还没说到汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）说那让我想起了我。在我说出来之前，她说你刚才读了一些关于你自己的东西。
okay so so you found yourself both in captain bentine and in sitting bull i think that nothing to be ashamed of about that sitting bull's father sitting bull's father um i think sitting bull as well so so sitting bull's original, do you know what his original name is? No, Sit or something? No, he later is called Slow. Slow, that's right, yeah. But before then, he's called Jumping Badger. Oh, I like that.
好的，所以你发现自己既在本廷上尉身上，也在坐牛身上，我认为这没什么可羞耻的。坐牛的父亲，坐牛的父亲，嗯，我想坐牛也是，所以坐牛最初的，你知道他最初的名字是什么吗？不，坐着什么的？不，他后来被称为“慢”（Slow）。慢，没错，是的。但在那之前，他被称为“跳跃的獾”（Jumping Badger）。哦，我喜欢那个。
Jumping Badger's a great name. Jumping Badger is his official name, but people nickname him Slow because apparently, well, there are two possible reasons. One is that he's literally quite slow, but the other other is just more plausible is that he always thinks before talking and he's very deliberate and considered so again like crazy horse getting off his horse to aim his gun exactly now interestingly that the sitting bull name that comes into the equation when his father has a chat with a buffalo. It's a buffalo who tells his father about this. So Returns Again and some other men are sitting around a campfire and this buffalo arrives
跳跃的獾是一个伟大的名字。跳跃的獾是他的正式名字，但人们给他起绰号叫“慢”，因为显然，嗯，有两种可能的原因。一种是他确实很慢，但另一种更合理的是，他总是先思考再说话，而且他非常深思熟虑，所以就像疯马从马上下来瞄准他的枪一样，正是。现在有趣的是，坐牛这个名字是在他父亲和一头野牛聊天时进入等式的。是一头野牛告诉他父亲关于这个名字的。所以“再次归来”和其他一些人坐在篝火旁，这头野牛来了，
and starts sort of bellowing at them, grunting. Oh, bellowing? And the buffalo kind of wobbles from side to side. And I read that Return Again's companions were awestruck, but Return Again understood what the buffalo was saying. What the buffalo was saying was, i've never done a buffalo i don't know what a buffalo's voice sounds like oh yeah it'd be deep it'd be very deep i can do a buffalo can you the buffalo gives him four names so the four names buffalo ball sits down jumping ball ball stands with cow and one ball i felt you threw Buffalo Bull Sits Down, Jumping Bull, Bull Stands With Cow, and One Bull. I felt you threw those away to some degree, Tom.
开始有点对他们咆哮，咕噜叫。哦，咆哮？野牛有点左右摇晃。我读到“再次归来”的同伴们感到敬畏，但“再次归来”听懂了野牛在说什么。野牛在说什么，我从来没做过野牛，我不知道野牛的声音听起来像什么，哦，是的，它会很深，它会非常深，我可以模仿野牛，你可以吗？野牛给了他四个名字，所以这四个名字是：野牛坐下（Buffalo Bull Sits Down）、跳跃的牛（Jumping Bull）、牛与母牛站在一起（Bull Stands With Cow）和一头牛（One Bull）。我觉得你把这些扔掉了，汤姆。
Actually, I thought it would be more... I mean, a buffalo's not a showman. Okay, he's not appearing in Buffalo Bill's show. No. No, I mean, he says the names and then he goes off and eats his grass. He does. So he says these four names, Buffalo Bull Sits Down, Jumping Bull, Bull Stands With Cow, and One Bull.
实际上，我认为它会更……我是说，野牛不是表演者。好的，他没有出现在布法罗·比尔的表演中。不。不，我是说，他说出名字，然后就走开去吃草了。他确实。所以他说出了这四个名字：野牛坐下、跳跃的牛、牛与母牛站在一起和一头牛。
And four is a sacred number, by the way, to the Lakota. these four names buffalo bull sits down jumping bull bull stands with a cow and one bull and four is a sacred number by the way to the lakota and returns again is very very impressed with this and he thinks they're a gift to him these names he goes back to the village he says i'm changing my name i'm going to call myself basically buffalo bull sits down sitting bull that's what he calls himself so he's called that but his son isn't. So the man we think of as Sitting Bull is called Slow. He has a chat to an eagle around this point, Tom. He's about 30.
顺便说一句，四对拉科他人来说是一个神圣的数字。这四个名字：野牛坐下、跳跃的牛、牛与母牛站在一起和一头牛，顺便说一句，四对拉科他人来说是一个神圣的数字，而“再次归来”对此印象非常非常深刻，他认为它们是给他的礼物，这些名字。他回到村里，他说我要改名，我要称自己为“野牛坐下”，即坐牛（Sitting Bull），这就是他称呼自己的方式。所以他叫那个名字，但他儿子不叫。所以我们认为的坐牛被称为“慢”。他在这一点上和一只鹰聊天，汤姆。他大约 30 岁。
The eagle sings to him and sings, My father gave me this nation to care for. I'm trying to fulfill my duty. Do we know what the song was like? Was it a good song? I don't want to hear you doing an eagle. Okay. I mean, that could be for the bonus
鹰为他唱歌，唱道：“我的父亲把这个国家交给我照顾。我正在努力履行我的职责。”我们知道那首歌是什么样的吗？那是一首好歌吗？我不想听你模仿鹰。好的。我是说，那可以是给额外
for that West is History Club member subscribers. I'm amazed that this hasn't been done as a track. It'd be a concept album, wouldn't it? It'd be a proper concept album from the 70s. Sacred Spirit could do it. Definitely. So the eagle sings to him and says, you have a special responsibility,
《历史的余味》俱乐部会员订阅者的。我很惊讶这还没有被做成一首歌。那会是一张概念专辑，不是吗？那会是一张 70 年代的正经概念专辑。“神圣精神”（Sacred Spirit）可以做到。绝对可以。所以鹰为他唱歌，说，你有一个特殊的责任，
all of this kind of thing. And actually by this point, he's not very slow. He's really good at archery and hunting and all that kind of thing and then when he's 14 years old he has the great moment in his life when he counts his first coup yeah so he touches an enemy with a stick and they've gone out on a hunting expedition because he hasn't ever got any war honors and he's only 14 he's naked except for some beads and a sort of little loincloth. And he doesn't carry a weapon, but he knocks a crow off his horse with this stick. It's kind of very Homeric, isn't it?
诸如此类的事情。事实上，到了这个时候，他已经不慢了。他非常擅长射箭、打猎等等。在他14岁那年，他迎来了人生中的高光时刻，他完成了第一次“数勋”（coup）——是的，他用一根棍子触碰了一名敌人。他们当时正外出狩猎，因为他之前没有任何战争荣誉，而且才14岁，身上除了几颗珠子和一条小腰布外，几乎赤身裸体。他没有携带武器，却用这根棍子把一名克罗族人从马背上打了下来。这非常有荷马史诗的感觉，不是吗？
It's very Homeric. Kind of the great hero. When you read this stuff, it's, you know, much as we are sort of enjoying doing the voice of a buffalo and imagining eagles singing, it's no different to telling the stories of the Greek heroes. I mean, that's the sort of the imaginative world, I think.
确实非常有荷马史诗感。就像伟大的英雄一样。当你读到这些内容时，你知道，尽管我们像是在享受模仿水牛的声音、想象老鹰在歌唱，但这与讲述希腊英雄的故事并无二致。我的意思是，我认为这就是那种想象的世界。
Yeah. Anyway, he knocks this bloke off his horse with a stick. His friends then rush up and they scalp the guy and kill him. And this is a tremendous moment for Slow. He goes back home. He has a great parade. His body is painted black and he has a single eagle feather
是的。总之，他用一根棍子把那个家伙从马背上打了下来。他的朋友们随后冲上去，剥了那个人的头皮并杀了他。这对“慢”（Slow）来说是一个了不起的时刻。他回到家，举行了盛大的游行。他的身体被涂成黑色，头上插着一根鹰羽，
in his hair to mark his coup and his father sort of stands up in front of everybody and he says great moment for my son and in honor of this moment i will change my name again and i will now be jumping bull and my son you are the new sitting bull and this seems to be a thing then doesn't it so crazy horse's dad hands on his name yeah and now the guy who's going to become sitting bull has handed on his name has handed on his name and i think we should take a break there tom because it's such an exciting and moving moment and we'll return afterwards to talk about how sitting bull how his career unfolds we haven't really talked about religion at all i know you like to talk about religion, so we'll talk about sun dancing.
以纪念他的“数勋”。他的父亲在众人面前站起来说：“这是我儿子的伟大时刻，为了纪念这一刻，我将再次改名，我现在叫‘跳跃的公牛’（Jumping Bull），而我的儿子，你就是新的‘坐牛’（Sitting Bull）。”这似乎成了一种传统，不是吗？疯马的父亲把名字传给了他，现在即将成为“坐牛”的那个人也把名字传了下去。我想我们该休息一下了，汤姆，因为这是一个如此激动人心且感人的时刻。休息之后，我们将回来讨论“坐牛”的职业生涯是如何展开的。我们还没怎么谈过宗教，我知道你喜欢谈论宗教，所以我们会谈谈“太阳舞”。
But Dominic, you will also know that I am suspicious of the use of the word religion. Of course, what a schoolboy error. In this context, because they don't have a notion of religion as something separate. Yeah. And this is the crucial point. Why shouldn't eagles talk? Why shouldn't bulls talk? Okay, agreed.
但是多米尼克，你也知道我对使用“宗教”这个词持怀疑态度。当然，这真是个学生气的错误。在这种语境下，因为他们没有将宗教视为某种独立事物的概念。是的，这是关键点。为什么老鹰不能说话？为什么公牛不能说话？好吧，同意。
Because the wonder and power of the supernatural is manifest in everything. I was trying to get us to the break, but I failed because I made it. I made a schoolboy error. You did. You walked into that one. And I walked right into it.
因为超自然现象的奇迹和力量在万物中显现。我刚才试图带我们进入休息时间，但我失败了，因为我犯了一个学生气的错误。你确实犯了。你自投罗网了。而我正好撞了上去。
Like Custer charging the little big horn. Custer, the nominal topic of this series, will return at the very end of this episode. So that's something to look forward to. We'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
就像卡斯特冲向小大角河一样。卡斯特，本系列的名义主题，将在本集最后回归。所以这很值得期待。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和优先购买现场票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是
therestisentertainment.com. Comrades, whoever runs away, he is a woman, they say. Therefore, through many trials, he is a woman, they say. Therefore, through many trials, my life is short. So that, Dominic, was a song sung by Sitting Bull as he charged a Crow Chieftain in 1856. Apparently he had a very high resonant singing voice like mine. Yeah, it could not have been less like what I imagine.
therestisentertainment.com。“同志们，谁逃跑，谁就是女人，他们说。因此，历经磨难，我的生命短暂。”所以，多米尼克，那是“坐牛”在1856年冲向一名克罗族酋长时唱的一首歌。显然，他有着像我一样非常洪亮的高音歌喉。是的，这和我想象中的样子简直天差地别。
Should I do it again? No, for God's sake, don't do it again. No, he's 25. Yeah. That's not the voice of a 24-year-old man, Tom. And this is a highly significant moment in Sitting Bull's career, isn't it? Because we were talking about the Homeric quality of his life before the break. And this is kind of Achilles against Hector. It is.
我要再唱一遍吗？不，看在上帝的份上，别再唱了。不，他当时25岁。是的。那不是一个24岁男人的声音，汤姆。这是“坐牛”职业生涯中一个非常重要的时刻，不是吗？因为我们在休息前谈到了他生命中的荷马史诗特质。这就像阿喀琉斯对阵赫克托耳。确实如此。
It's a standoff between two mighty warriors on rival sides and everybody else has stood back to watch it. The crow drops to one knee and he's got a rifle. He fires. The bullet goes through the shield that Sitting Bull is holding and goes into his left foot rather oddly it must have been quite a bad shot i think yeah and it goes in at his toe and goes out his heel yeah so again kind of very achilles and now sitting bull turns aims his rifle fires the crow chief tumbles sitting bull takes out his knife obviously he's got a bullet through his foot so he's got to limp yeah he takes his knife raises it over
这是两位强大战士在敌对阵营之间的对峙，其他人都在一旁观看。那个克罗族人单膝跪地，手里拿着一支步枪。他开火了。子弹穿过了“坐牛”拿着的盾牌，射进了他的左脚。奇怪的是，那一定是一次很糟糕的射击，我想。是的，子弹从他的脚趾射入，从脚后跟射出。是的，所以这又非常有阿喀琉斯的风格。现在“坐牛”转身，瞄准步枪，开火，克罗族酋长倒下了。“坐牛”拔出刀，显然他的脚中弹了，所以他不得不一瘸一拐地走。是的，他拔出刀，举过
his fallen opponent plunges it into the heart yeah thrilling stuff it is exciting stuff makes Sitting Bull a great hero
他倒下的对手，刺入了他的心脏。是的，惊心动魄，确实令人兴奋，这让“坐牛”成为了伟大的英雄。
gets all kinds of war on us and actually the song the idea of him singing the song so that reminds me of the Norse sagas or something
他获得了各种战争荣誉。事实上，他唱这首歌的想法让我想起了北欧萨迦之类的东西。
yeah kind of skaldic verse. They are, aren't they? They're like, he raised his axe, smote the guy's head, and he sang as he did so. Yeah. So there were Viking chieftains who are famous for their ability to do this and to sing and celebrate their own victories. Yeah.
是的，有点像斯卡尔德诗歌。它们确实是这样，不是吗？就像是：他举起斧头，击碎了那家伙的头，他在这样做时还唱着歌。是的。所以确实有以这种能力、以歌唱和庆祝自己胜利而闻名的维京酋长。是的。
And this is clearly what Sitting Bull is doing. Yeah. And I think, I mean, this is the weird thing about this whole story, that this world that feels very reminiscent of Homeric epic or Norse epic is taking place in the same arena as there are railroads and the Aster family and Custer and all of these things that are from the world of modernity. I mean, that's what makes the story so rich and so fascinating, isn't it? Yeah. And I think also the fact that custer is the kind of intersection point between those two worlds yeah i mean he's he is cast as a kind of knight errant from medieval chivalry and sitting bull is cast as a homeric or norse warrior and so this is part of the dynamic of the story that makes it so interesting to people back in the 19th century
这显然就是“坐牛”在做的事情。是的。我认为，整个故事最奇怪的地方在于，这个让人想起荷马史诗或北欧史诗的世界，竟然与铁路、阿斯特家族、卡斯特以及所有这些现代世界的产物发生在同一个舞台上。我的意思是，这正是让这个故事如此丰富和迷人的原因，不是吗？是的。而且我认为，卡斯特作为这两个世界之间的交汇点，也是一个事实。是的，我的意思是，他被塑造成中世纪骑士精神中的一种游侠，而“坐牛”被塑造成荷马或北欧式的战士，所以这是故事动态的一部分，让19世纪的人们对它如此感兴趣，
but also let's be honest to us yes of course absolutely yeah i completely agree anyway sitting bull by the 1860s by his sort of 20s 30s he's a big man he is a very celebrated warrior he has a great buffalo kind of um horned headdress with feathers to show that he has won all these victories and killed all these chiefs and things. We talked before, I think we were talking about the dog soldiers and the Cheyenne. We were talking about how they had these kind of warrior fraternities. He's in loads of them and he's an officer of loads of these fraternities, which is a real achievement. And actually, although they don't really have a kind of
但老实说，对我们来说也是如此。是的，当然，绝对是。我完全同意。总之，“坐牛”到了19世纪60年代，也就是他20多岁、30多岁的时候，他已经是一个大人物了。他是一位非常著名的战士，他有一个巨大的水牛角头饰，上面有羽毛，以显示他赢得了所有这些胜利，杀死了所有这些酋长等等。我们之前谈过，我想我们当时在谈论夏延族的“狗士兵”。我们谈到他们有这些战士兄弟会。他参加了很多，并且是其中许多兄弟会的官员，这真是一个了不起的成就。事实上，虽然他们并没有一种
formal political structure they have an informal one he's very high in it and it's prestige based isn't it it is prestige base but the biggest thing about him that makes him different and gives him this fascination is his holiness is the sense that he has a link to what you undoubtedly would call the dimension of the supernatural. One of my favorite phrases, as people will know. It is. So he's danced the sun dance. Oh, yeah. I mean, this must be something that you must love all this.
正式的政治结构，但他们有一种非正式的结构，他在其中地位很高，而且这是基于声望的，不是吗？确实是基于声望的，但他与众不同并赋予他这种魅力的地方在于他的神圣性，即他与你无疑会称之为“超自然维度”的东西有着某种联系。这是我最喜欢的短语之一，正如人们所知。确实如此。所以他跳了“太阳舞”。哦，是的。我的意思是，这一定是你必须喜欢的东西。
I really do. Because you basically love torture and religion. I know religion is not the right word. Yeah. This combines both your interests. Yes. So the sun dance is a kind of big thing. It provides an opportunity to directly see into the dimension of the supernatural, to be given visions of the future, to be given advice
我确实喜欢。因为你基本上喜欢折磨和宗教。我知道“宗教”不是正确的词。是的。这结合了你的两种兴趣。是的。所以“太阳舞”是一件大事。它提供了一个直接窥视超自然维度的机会，被赋予对未来的愿景，被赋予建议，
for what you should do that derives from the gods, from the spirits that lie beyond the realm of the human. And the big god is Wakan Tanka. That's right, isn't it? He is the kind of great father. The great mystery. The great mystery, yeah. So the sense he's great spirit, the great mystery. Dominant you as the master of tongues, presumably you would be alert to that way in which... Very alert to the nuances, yeah. The sense of mystery, but also spirit is an important part of what's being tapped into.
告诉你应该做什么，这些建议源于神灵，源于存在于人类领域之外的灵魂。而伟大的神是“瓦坎·坦卡”（Wakan Tanka）。没错，是这样吧？他是某种伟大的父亲。伟大的神秘。伟大的神秘，是的。所以那种他是伟大精神、伟大神秘的感觉。多米尼克，作为语言大师，想必你会对那种方式保持警觉……对细微差别非常警觉，是的。神秘感，但精神也是被挖掘出来的重要部分。
I think it is. And I think it's sort of less anthropomorphic than the kind of mythology that we associate with greece or the one day you know it's not all sort of people stealing each other's wives and wooden horses or all of that kind of it's more mysterious than that isn't it the world of lakota faith well it's shamanistic i guess would be the word that anthropologists would use yes um i mean probably anthropologists are now suspicious of the word shamanistic, I guess, would be the word that anthropologists would use. Yes. I mean, probably anthropologists are now suspicious of the word shamanistic. Yeah. But the idea that you put yourself through excruciating austerities and physical pain and open yourself up to visions that you wouldn't otherwise have.
我认为是这样。而且我认为它比我们与希腊神话联系在一起的那种神话更少拟人化，你知道，那不是所有人都在偷对方的妻子、木马之类的东西，它比那更神秘，不是吗？拉科塔信仰的世界。好吧，我想人类学家会用“萨满教”这个词。是的，嗯，我的意思是，可能人类学家现在对“萨满教”这个词持怀疑态度。是的，我的意思是，可能人类学家现在对“萨满教”这个词持怀疑态度。是的。但那种你让自己经历极度苦行和身体痛苦，并向你原本不会有的愿景敞开自己的想法。
So we were talking about medicine yesterday, that you either have medicine or you don't. And Sitting Bull definitely does. And there seem to be kind of two ways that are associated with the Sundance. So one, which Sitting Bull does shortly before the Battle of the Little Bighorn, is that you give flesh. So Sitting Bull will have someone take out 50 kind of gobbets of flesh
所以我们昨天谈到了“药”（medicine），即你要么有“药”，要么没有。而“坐牛”绝对有。而且似乎有两种与“太阳舞”相关的方式。一种是“坐牛”在小大角河战役前不久做的，就是你献出肉体。所以“坐牛”会让某人取出50块肉，
from each of his arms. Yeah, they're often described as the size of the head of a match. So they're quite small, but somebody will basically go at your arm with an awl and they will rip out 50 bits of flesh and as an offering to the gods but the sun dance itself it sounds to me is an absolute worse even worse much worse yeah so so you set up uh buffalo heads in a kind circle, and then you have a medicine pole, which is fixed into the ground.
从他的每条手臂上。是的，它们通常被描述为火柴头大小。所以它们很小，但有人基本上会用锥子刺向你的手臂，他们会撕下50块肉作为给神灵的祭品。但“太阳舞”本身，听起来对我来说绝对更糟，甚至更糟，糟糕得多。是的，所以你把水牛头摆成一个圆圈，然后你有一根“药柱”，固定在地上。
And what is it? You have a pole, don't you? So, yeah, you have this big pole. Actually, medicine pole, it is called a medicine pole, but as we said last time, the language of medicine is very unhelpful. Yeah, it's not a kind of thing you get at the NHS. So there's this huge pole. Everyone assembles. There's a big feast.
那是什么？你有一根柱子，对吧？所以，是的，你有这根大柱子。事实上，它被称为“药柱”，但正如我们上次所说，关于“药”的语言非常无用。是的，它不是那种你在国民医疗服务体系（NHS）里能得到的东西。所以有这根巨大的柱子。每个人都聚集在一起。有一场盛大的宴会。
You know, it's like on a religious feast festival. Lots of people have assembled. They've been drinking and they've been dancing and they've been having fun and stuff. But now it's very solemn. And they watch while you step forward and whoever else is going to do the Sundance. And a holy man, basically, he pierces your skin around your nipples. It goes under the muscles, doesn't it? And he puts a sort of skewer through it, a wooden skewer.
你知道，就像在宗教节日里一样。很多人聚集在一起。他们一直在喝酒，一直在跳舞，一直在玩乐等等。但现在非常庄严。他们看着你走上前，以及其他任何要参加“太阳舞”的人。一位圣人，基本上，他刺穿你乳头周围的皮肤。它穿过肌肉下面，对吧？他穿过一根木签，一种木制的签子。
And then he ties leather thongs to this skewer. And those are then tied to a rope. A lariat, I believe, is the technical word. Right. And the rope is tied to the pole. And it's tightened so that you have to stand on your feet. It's so horrible. And I mean, that's the basic package, but you can have worse ones, which will obviously
然后他把皮带系在这个签子上。这些皮带随后被系在一根绳子上。我相信技术术语是“套索”（lariat）。对。绳子系在柱子上。它被拉紧，所以你必须用脚站立。这太可怕了。我的意思是，这是基本套餐，但你可以有更糟的，这显然会
raise your prestige because they're much more painful. So you might have sticks that get pushed through the cheeks of the dancer just beneath the eyes, or you might have them through the back muscles, which are obviously very dense. So I mean, that would be completely excruciating. So essentially you get kind of hooked up by these and you then get given a whistle and you have to blow on the whistle yeah and then you have to dance and they will be drumming and stuff won't they while you're dancing yeah but you have to dance for hours and hours and hours and you have to lift your face to the sun yeah and while you're doing it you're kind of giving away various stuff so you might give away a weapon or a pony or or something like
提高你的声望，因为它们更痛苦。所以你可能会有棍子穿过舞者的脸颊，就在眼睛下方，或者你可能会让它们穿过背部肌肉，这些肌肉显然非常致密。所以我的意思是，那将是完全痛苦的。所以本质上你被这些东西钩住，然后你被给了一个哨子，你必须吹哨子。是的，然后你必须跳舞，他们会敲鼓之类的，对吧？当你跳舞的时候。是的，但你必须跳上几个小时，而且你必须把脸抬向太阳。是的，当你这样做的时候，你是在分发各种东西，所以你可能会分发一件武器、一匹小马或类似的东西。
that and again those who are going to the limits, those who've got the sticks through their muscles or whatever, they will give everything away. So there are even warriors who give away their sisters, which must have been a bit grim for the sister, I guess. Very grim for the sister, yeah. And the thing is that if you fail the test, so if you don't measure up,
同样，那些达到极限的人，那些肌肉里穿过棍子的人，他们会把一切都分发出去。所以甚至有战士把他们的姐妹分发出去，这对姐妹来说一定有点残酷，我想。对姐妹来说非常残酷，是的。问题是，如果你没通过测试，也就是说，如果你达不到要求，
if you think you can do it and it proves you can't, you faint't you faint or you just say oh god this hurts too much i'm stopping yeah then you lose your status as a warrior you're given a woman's dress and you are set to picking berries or doing the washing up or whatever to be honest i mean i can see why you might choose that voluntarily you know it's a good way to get into the berry picking business. I mean, it sounds horrendous. So you basically, the point of the dance is to try and break free from the hooks, isn't it?
如果你认为你能做到，但事实证明你不能，你晕倒了，或者你只是说“哦上帝，这太痛了，我停下来”。是的，那么你就失去了战士的身份，你会被穿上女人的衣服，被派去采摘浆果或洗碗之类的。老实说，我的意思是，我能看出为什么你可能会自愿选择那样，你知道，这是一个进入浆果采摘行业的好方法。我的意思是，这听起来很可怕。所以你基本上，舞蹈的目的是试图从钩子中挣脱出来，对吧？
I think it's to have a vision. Yeah. Oh, of course. Yeah. You'll have the vision through pain. That's the point. Correct. But if you just faint and you don't have the vision, that's no good. Yeah, no good.
我认为是为了获得愿景。是的。哦，当然。是的。你会通过痛苦获得愿景。这就是重点。正确。但如果你只是晕倒了，没有获得愿景，那就不好了。是的，不好。
I mean, it is weird. On the other hand, I suppose, I think it's really worth stressing that to us in 2024, as kind of people living in a fairly secular country, it seems extremely unsettling. But is it any more weird and unsettling than so many other religious rituals? I mean, think about the self-mortification in Christianity. Or people going off into the desert and taking drugs and having visions that way. People want vision, people taking acid. Yeah, absolutely. So Sitting Bull does this, doesn't he? And nobody doubts that he is a very holy man, that he has enormous endurance and he will show off all of the scars, his scars on his
我的意思是，这很奇怪。另一方面，我想，我认为非常值得强调的是，对我们2024年生活在一个相当世俗国家的人来说，这看起来极其令人不安。但这比其他许多宗教仪式更奇怪、更令人不安吗？我的意思是，想想基督教中的自我苦行。或者人们去沙漠里服用药物并以那种方式获得愿景。人们想要愿景，人们服用迷幻药。是的，绝对。所以“坐牛”做了这个，不是吗？没有人怀疑他是一个非常神圣的人，他有巨大的耐力，他会炫耀所有的伤疤，他胸部的伤疤，
chest, his scars on his back, he has scars on his arms that are testament to his courage in various sun dances and similar kind of religious rituals. And he's a large man, isn't he? Yeah, he's a big man. So there's quite a lot of him to take bits of flesh out of, to gouge out. Yes, because he becomes, obviously later on, after the Battle of Little Bighorn, because he becomes such a celebrity. I mean, there's no other word for it.
他背部的伤疤，他手臂上的伤疤，这些都是他在各种“太阳舞”和类似的宗教仪式中表现出勇气的证明。而且他是一个大块头，不是吗？是的，他是一个大人物。所以他身上有很多地方可以取出肉块，可以挖出来。是的，因为他后来，显然在小大角河战役之后，因为他成为了如此大的名人。我的意思是，没有别的词可以形容了。
He's an international celebrity. Well, so as well as the handshaking after Little Bighorn, he is also shown how to write his name. And his autograph apparently was the most prized after the president's. I mean, I would much rather have Sitting Bull's autograph
他是一位国际名人。好吧，除了小大角河战役后的握手，他还被教导如何写自己的名字。显然，他的签名是继总统之后最抢手的。我的意思是，我宁愿要“坐牛”的签名，
than some of the presidents of the 1880s who nobody remembers. Yeah, of course. I mean, who wants Chester Arthur's autograph when you could have Sitting Bull's autograph? Anyway, so later on when he's a celebrity, all these stories are told about him and nobody ever undermines him or questions his holiness. So people say, listen, this is a chap. He's always communing with badgers, doing all this stuff, getting information from the spirit world.
也不要1880年代某些没人记得的总统的签名。是的，当然。我的意思是，当你可以拥有“坐牛”的签名时，谁想要切斯特·阿瑟的签名？总之，后来当他成为名人时，所有关于他的故事都被讲述出来，没有人会破坏或质疑他的神圣性。所以人们说，听着，这是一个家伙。他总是与獾交流，做所有这些事情，从精神世界获取信息。
Bulls, eagles. Yeah. He can see into the future and his predictions are generally right. He will say, we will have meat in the spring, all this kind of stuff. And this ability to foretell the future will be crucial for the buildup to the Battle of Little Bighorn. So just keep that in mind. It will indeed. It will indeed.
公牛，老鹰。是的。他能预见未来，他的预测通常是正确的。他会说，春天我们会有肉吃，诸如此类的事情。而这种预见未来的能力对于小大角河战役的酝酿至关重要。所以请记住这一点。确实会如此。确实会如此。
But also, the interesting thing about him, I think the likable thing, Tom, is that he's not a sort of a stereotypical caricatured sort of very forbidding holy man, is he? He's a laugh. No, he's fun. He's good fun. He loves singing, as you have beautifully demonstrated. Yeah. He's a very good mimic.
但同样，关于他有趣的事情，我认为讨人喜欢的事情，汤姆，是他不是那种刻板印象中非常令人望而生畏的圣人，对吧？他很有趣。不，他很有趣。他很有趣。他喜欢唱歌，正如你精彩地展示的那样。是的。他是一个非常好的模仿者。
Yeah. He likes jokes. Very good actor. Yeah. He's, like me, a very good actor. And very affectionate as well to people he loves yeah he's a nice person it's a nice person also he struggles with his mental health tom did you see this he suffers from bouts of depression i didn't know that so it's very
是的。他喜欢笑话。非常好的演员。是的。他像我一样，是一个非常好的演员。而且对所爱的人也非常深情。是的，他是一个好人，这是一个好人。而且他还在与心理健康作斗争，汤姆，你看到了吗？他患有抑郁症。我不知道这一点。所以这在某种意义上非常
relatable in that sense anyway the one thing that perhaps is well i don't know what what listeners will think whether it's relatable or not. After Red Cloud has done this deal and said, fine, let's yield to reality. We'll go on this big reservation in South Dakota. Sitting Bull, the one thing that really marks him out, he says, no way. Absolutely no way. I will never, ever compromise with Washington, with the Americans. And he says of Red Cloud, he said, Red Cloud saw too much. The white people must have put bad medicine over Red Cloud's eyes to make him see
容易引起共鸣。总之，有一件事也许是……我不知道听众会怎么想，是否容易引起共鸣。在红云（Red Cloud）达成这笔交易并说：“好吧，让我们向现实屈服吧。我们将去南达科他州的这个大保留地。”“坐牛”，真正让他与众不同的一点是，他说：“没门。绝对没门。我永远、永远不会与华盛顿、与美国人妥协。”他谈到红云时说，他说：“红云看得太多了。白人一定给红云的眼睛施了邪恶的‘药’，让他看到
everything and anything that they pleased. This is after Red Cloud's trip to Washington. And when people say to him, listen, if we go on the reservation, sure, it won't be as exciting and it won't be shooting crows through the heart or all that stuff that was great fun before however you know we'll have food and we'll have somewhere to live and we'll be safe he says look at me see if i am poor or my people either the whites may get me at last as you say but i will have good times till then you are fools to make yourself slaves to a piece of fat bacon, some hard tack and a little sugar and coffee. And of course, the thing is, there are loads of people who would agree with
他们想要的任何东西。”这是在红云去华盛顿之后。当人们对他说：“听着，如果我们去保留地，当然，它不会那么令人兴奋，也不会有射击克罗族人的心脏或之前那些很有趣的事情，然而，你知道，我们将有食物，我们将有地方住，我们将是安全的。”他说：“看看我，看看我是否贫穷，或者我的人民是否贫穷。白人最终可能会抓住我，正如你所说，但在那之前我会有美好的时光。你们这些傻瓜，为了一块肥肉、一些硬饼干和一点糖和咖啡，就把自己变成奴隶。”当然，事实是，有很多人会同意
that. Of course. Particularly younger warriors who want to have, they want to make a name for themselves. But also as you made the point last time, didn't you? It's exhilarating. I mean, it must be terrifying at times, but it's exciting. I assume that you don't need to divide it into saying, well, it's simultaneously fun and noble because to be noble is to be fun, I guess. Yeah, I guess that's right. I think that's right. And I think there are also a lot of people who say, do you know what? We could kind of do both. I mean, this undoubtedly happens. There are lots of people who say, in the winter, I'll go to the reservation. I'll hang around. I'll have that coffee and make small talk with the federal agent. And then when summer comes, I'm out of here.
这一点。当然。特别是那些想要成名的年轻战士。但正如你上次指出的那样，不是吗？这令人振奋。我的意思是，有时这一定很可怕，但它很令人兴奋。我假设你不需要把它分开说，好吧，它既有趣又高尚，因为高尚就是有趣，我想。是的，我想那是对的。我认为那是对的。而且我认为也有很多人说：“你知道吗？我们可以两者兼顾。”我的意思是，这无疑会发生。有很多人说：“冬天，我会去保留地。我会待在那里。我会喝那杯咖啡，和联邦特工闲聊。然后夏天来了，我就离开这里。”
Well, again, as we'll see at the Battle of Little Bighorn, a lot of reservation Dakota are there. Yeah. So there's not a neat sort of very stark divide between the reservation and non-reservation Indians. But the man who says, I'm not having this, I'm not compromising, I'm staying free, obviously comes to be a figure of tremendous charisma and significance. Yes.
好吧，正如我们将在小大角河战役中看到的那样，很多保留地的达科他人都在那里。是的。所以保留地和非保留地的印第安人之间并没有一个整齐、非常鲜明的界限。但是那个说“我不接受这个，我不妥协，我要保持自由”的人，显然成为了一个具有巨大魅力和重要性的人物。是的。
So the fact that Sitting Bull has done that is what enables him to serve as the focus of loyalty, admiration, devotion for so many of the younger warriors. Yeah. So by the end of the 186060s he has now achieved a position that really nobody has ever achieved before he's almost a sort of paramount chief and they have a big meeting in 1869 of the of the lakota who are dead against the reservation and at that his uncle who's got four horns says to him for your bravery on the battlefields and as the greatest warrior of our bands we've elected you as our war chief as leader of the sioux nation when you tell us to fight we shall fight when you tell us to make peace we shall make peace so in other words he's been cast in this new kind of role which is again another sign of how it's
所以“坐牛”做到了这一点，这使他能够成为许多年轻战士忠诚、钦佩、奉献的焦点。是的。所以到了19世纪60年代末，他现在已经达到了一个以前从未有人达到过的地位，他几乎是一个某种最高酋长。1869年，他们举行了一次大型会议，反对保留地的拉科塔人参加了会议。在那次会议上，他的叔叔“四角”（Four Horns）对他说：“因为你在战场上的勇敢，作为我们部落最伟大的战士，我们选举你为我们的战争酋长，作为苏族国家的领袖。当你告诉我们战斗时，我们将战斗；当你告诉我们讲和时，我们将讲和。”所以换句话说，他被赋予了这种新的角色，这又是它
not actually a timeless culture no it's evolving in response to the pressures on it exactly so exactly so in the late 1860s early 1870s sitting bull is sending people on raids and things but they're all quite small scale however all the time the railroad is coming closer and one railroad in particular which is the northern pacific and the northern pacific has basically decided on its route and that route leads right through the lakota lands in 1872 they sent out a survey party and sitting bull and crazy horse because crazy horse is also holding out of course they got together to see it off. And then a year later, in the summer of 1873, Sitting Bull, it's been a quiet summer and they're kind of minding their own business, kind of, you know, they're going out hunting. He's talking to eagles and doing his thing.
实际上不是一种永恒文化的标志，不，它正在随着压力而演变。完全正确，所以完全正确。在19世纪60年代末70年代初，“坐牛”正在派遣人们进行突袭等等，但规模都很小。然而，铁路一直在靠近，特别是其中一条铁路，即北太平洋铁路。北太平洋铁路基本上已经决定了它的路线，那条路线直接穿过拉科塔人的土地。1872年，他们派出了一个勘测队，“坐牛”和“疯马”（因为“疯马”当然也在坚持）聚在一起把他们赶走了。然后一年后，在1873年的夏天，“坐牛”，那是一个安静的夏天，他们有点各忙各的，你知道，他们出去打猎。他正在和老鹰交谈，做他自己的事情。
And then he hears news that a new survey expedition with a US Army escort is advancing on the Yellowstone River. And the head of this expedition, Tom. Who is it, Dominic? Who is it? None other than our old friend, George Armstrong Custer. And on that bombshell, we should draw a close over the story. And we will return next time to find out what happens at the Yellowstone between Custer
然后他听到消息说，一支带有美国陆军护卫的新勘测探险队正在向黄石河推进。而这支探险队的负责人，汤姆。是谁，多米尼克？是谁？正是我们的老朋友，乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们应该结束这个故事了。我们下次将回来了解在黄石河，卡斯特
and Sitting Bull and we'll get into the story of the Black Hills Expedition a year later. Yeah that's a terrible story. Now if you want to hear the rest of this thrilling series early before everybody else then you know what to do. You just need to go to
和“坐牛”之间发生了什么，我们将进入一年后的黑山探险的故事。是的，那是一个可怕的故事。现在，如果你想在其他人之前听到这个激动人心的系列的其余部分，那么你知道该怎么做。你只需要去
therestishistory.com sign up to join our warrior band. You get all kinds of thrilling benefits, but most importantly, you will get those episodes before your neighbours, and so you can lord it over them because you will know what happened to George Armstrong Custer, but they won't. I mean, amazing, we've got four episodes to go.
therestishistory.com 注册加入我们的战士部落。你会得到各种激动人心的福利，但最重要的是，你会比你的邻居先听到这些剧集，这样你就可以在他们面前炫耀，因为你会知道乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特发生了什么，而他们不知道。我的意思是，太棒了，我们还有四集。
Yeah. We did the whole of the Reformation in five episodes. I'm so bitter about this. So bitter. So many complaints that I hear about that. And I was only allowed four on Byron. Exactly. This is the thing. The complaint isn't really that there are too many on the Lakota. Your complaint is that you weren't given enough on Byron. No, I stuck to our agreement and you're just spraying notes everywhere you go.
是的。我们用五集完成了整个宗教改革。我对此感到非常痛苦。非常痛苦。我听到了很多关于那个的抱怨。而我只被允许在拜伦身上用四集。正是如此。这就是问题所在。抱怨的并不是拉科塔人有太多集。你的抱怨是你没有在拜伦身上得到足够的集数。不，我坚持了我们的协议，而你走到哪里都在喷洒笔记。
No. Roaming like a Lakota chieftain. No, it's a gross calumny because when I send you the notes thinking you'll suggest things to cut, which I would be delighted to hear, what actually happens... I just shovel a whole load more in myself.
不。像拉科塔酋长一样漫游。不，这是一种严重的诽谤，因为当我把笔记发给你，以为你会建议删减什么，我很乐意听到，但实际上发生的是……我自己又铲了一大堆进去。
...is that you shovel a whole load of new notes in. The only thing you wanted to cut and you rang me up and a great agitation about was you said... Yeah. Custer's father's beard. i just felt that was an extraneous detail an extraneous detail that custer's father had a beard but that was really important people don't want to go back and listen to episode one there's a lot of custer's father beard related
……是你自己铲了一大堆新笔记进去。你唯一想删减的，并且你打电话给我，非常激动地说的是……是的。卡斯特父亲的胡子。我只是觉得那是一个无关紧要的细节，卡斯特父亲有胡子是一个无关紧要的细节，但这真的很重要，人们不想回去听第一集，有很多关于卡斯特父亲胡子的
badinage going on and this is the subtext for it yeah anyway listen we will be back we still have four episodes to go. The build up to the battle of the Little Bighorn, the battle itself, and then the aftermath and the tragic, terrible story of the Ghost Dancers.
戏谑，这就是它的潜台词。是的，总之，听着，我们会回来的，我们还有四集。小大角河战役的酝酿，战役本身，然后是后果，以及“鬼舞者”悲惨、可怕的故事。
So that is all to come. Wonderful. See you next time. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
所以这一切即将到来。太棒了。下次见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和优先购买现场票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。